bonsoir et bienvenue très heureuse de
vous retrouver dans Ça vous regarde ce
soir un écrivain dans la course au
goncour bonsoir Gaspar kenigons et merci
d'être notre grand témoin ce soir votre
roman humus aux éditions de
l'Observatoire fait donc partie des
quatre finalistes dévoilés hier roman
sur l'engagement écologiste de deux
jeunes agronomes pour les longs briques
les vers de terre indispensable à la VI
sur terre roman d'apprentissage aussi
autant que satire sociale on va en
parler longuement tous les deux dans la
deuxème partie ce soir notre grand débat
sur les réponses du gouvernement après
les émeutes urbaines de l'été dernier 4
mois après la première ministre a
rassemblé 500 maires à la Sorbonne pour
annoncer une série de mesures
régaliennes autorité parentale police
justice la fermeté la sécurité sont
clairement les priorités nous en
débattons dans un tout petit instant
avec mes invités sur ce plateau enfin
nous affranchi ce soir le parti prix
politique de yalgos le regard sur le
monde de Vincent eugu et puis bbon
Express raconté par l'excellente Elsa
Mondin Gava voilà pour le menu on y va
Gaspard Kenck ça vous regarde c'est
[Musique]
maintenant 500 mA tous concer é par les
émeutes de juillet dernier quatre
ministres la première d'entre elles le
tout dans l'amphithéâtre de la Sorbonne
la mise en scène était soigné il y a
quelques heures à la Sorbonne donc pour
dévoiler les réponses du gouvernement 4
mois après les violences urbaines police
justice autorité parentale on va y
revenir dans le détail avec mes invités
bonsoir Carl olive bonsoir bienvenue
vous êtes député renaissance des
Yvelines bonsoir Stéphane Troussel
bonsoir ravi de vous accueillir
président du conseil départemental de la
scène Saint-Denis bonsoir Mamadou Dialo
bonsoir bienvenue sur ce plateau
directeur de l'association Ziva à
Nanterre et enfin bonsoir abdouah Kanté
vous êtes policiers dans les hautes
scènes auteur de policiers enfants de la
République chez Fayard et engagé dans ce
qu'on appelle désormais le dialogue
police population Gaspar Kenig on n'est
pas sur vos terrains de prédilection
mais voilà comme citoyens on a tous été
marqués par ce qui s'est passé à l'été
n'hésitez pas à interroger nos invités
si si vous le souhaitez d'abord
qu'est-ce l' a dit la première ministre
quelles sont ses nouvelles annonces on
voit cela avec Stéphane blakovski dans
son chrono tout de
suite bonsoir Stéphane bonsoir Miriam
bonsoir messieurs alors ce plan 4 mois
après vous savez que il y a 4 mois donc
il y a 500 communes en France qui ont
été victimes de ces émeutes dans 66
départements et donc le gouvernement
présenta aujourd'hui des mesures pour
tenter de lutter contre ces violences
urbaines donc on attendait ces mesures
depuis assez longtemps donc sans doute
pour compenser un peu on a donné de la
sol é en invitant 500 mire à la Sorbonne
avec la présence de la première ministre
et de quatre ministres parce que
l'attente était lié au fait que le
Président vous le savez ne voulez pas
agir dans l'urgence laisser un peu le
temps à la réflexion et à la
concertation sauf qu'après 4 mois de
réflexion on a un peu l'impression que
les pistes sont exactement les mêmes que
celles qu'on avait imaginé immédiatement
après les émeutes regardez la première
chose que le président avait dit c'était
le retour à l'ordre et même plus que ça
le retour à l'ordre l'ordre l'ordre donc
sans surprise pour réétablir l'ordre
Élisabeth borne a proposé des mesures de
sécurité notamment la création de ce qui
s'appelle r la phare c'està dire force
d'action républicaine c'est pas quelque
chose de nouveau là non plus puce qu'en
fait c'était une promesse du candidat
Macron en 2002 qui voulait créer ses
forces d'action don le principe c'est de
regrouper au sein d'une seule équipe
différentes compétences policiers
magistrat même et éducateurs pour
intervenir ponctuellement dans des
quartiers très difficiles en crise on
écoute dans ces quartiers nous devons
avoir une réponse forte et globale c'est
le sens de la force d'action
républicaine proposée par le Président
de la République lors de la campagne
électorale son objectif sera de
concentrer dans un quartier tous les
efforts de l'État à vos côtés pendant
plusieurs mois à partir d'un diagnostic
commun nous déploirons des moyens pour
traiter les difficultés que les
populations rencontrent en matière de
sécurité mais aussi pour des réponses
judiciaires et
ou sociale alors à noter une autre
mesure annoncée dans le domaine de la
police la possibilité pour les maires
qu' le souhaiteront d'accorder leur
police municipale plus grande compét
celle qui se rapprocherait de la police
nationale c'est quelque chose que le
gouvernement veut travailler ensuite
quel est constat qu'on avait fait
immédiatement lors des meutes et ben
vous le voyez c'était inscrit dans les
journaux c'était la participation
importante notamment quand on faisait la
au niveau des des interpellation des
mineurs donc bien évidemment born
souhaitait intervenir sur ce sujet et
notamment s'assurer que il y aurait une
sanction à la moindre infraacction d'un
mineur et qu'on ne se contenterait donc
plus d'un simple rappel à à la loi en
écoute lors de ces émeutes nous avons
constaté qu'une grande partie des
auteurs mineurs n'avaent jamais eu à
faire à la justice il faut donc que nous
élargissions notre palette de sanction
afin qu'aucun acte ne reste
impuni il s'agit d'assurer une réponse
ferme effective et adaptée dès la
première infraction là on parle de
sanction dès la première infraction mais
pour des délinquants qui seraient un peu
plus endurcis la première ministre aussi
parler de centre fermé et du centre
fermé encadré par les militaires donc
j'imagine qu'on va beaucoup commenter
cet aspect sa décision et puis quelle
était le troisème point que on avait mis
d'emblé en avant mais alors dès le
lendemain des des émeutes et ben vous
allez le voir apparaître ici ce sont le
rôle des parents le président avait
pointé ça dans un tweet en plein milieu
des émeutes et d'ailleurs les Français
étaient assez convaincus que une des
premières causes de ces violences
urbaines c'était le manque
d'autorité des parents donc évidemment
on joue la carte de la fermeté dans tous
les domaines même par rapport aux
parents on écoute la première ministre
nous proposerons au Parlement que des
stages de responsabilité parental ou des
peines de travaux d'intérêt général
puissent être prononcé à l'encontre des
parents qui se soustrait à leurs devoirs
éducatifs alors j'ajoute aussi un petit
volet consacré au numérique pour éviter
qu'on puisse propager des images
violentes sans être sanctionné mais vous
allez voir que vous avvez vous allez
vous dire mais il y a que de fermeté on
a parlé que de la fermeté ce soir alors
rassurez-vous on débattre ça ce soir
mais demain nouveau volet cette fois-ci
la première ministre annonce des mesures
sociales d'accompagnement un peu plus
constructif peut-être oui d'ailleurs
merci beaucoup Stéphane sur ce point de
méthode Carl olive pourquoi séparer les
deux pourquoi séparer le volet
sécuritaire
régalien répressif du volet social
éducatif antidiscrimination sur de jours
ça peut ê perçu un peu comme s'il y
avait quelque chose de plus important
que que l'autre à savoir aujourd'hui
plutôt que demain d'abord d'abord merci
pour l'invitation euh la première chose
à dire c'est que le logiciel a changé
lorsqu'on a été
maire lorsque le président de la
République au début du mois de juillet
réunit les les de s m après les émeutes
il leur a donné la main en disant voilà
moi je veux coconstruire c'était
l'expression du président de la
République je veux construire avec vous
et tant mieux moi qui suis un ancien
maire de de de poissie enfin on vient
comme je dis sentir le terrain hm hm on
vient mettre à jour oui je sais ce que
vous allez dire j'ai fait une tribune
s'appelait allons sentir le cul des
vaches expression bretonne la vérité
c'est quand on passe du temps sur le
terrain poissier pas un microclimat mais
on a relativement été apaisé pourquoi
parce qu'on passe beaucoup de temps avec
les associations comme celle de de
Monsieur avec les référents de quartier
avec les éducateurs avec les policiers
nationaux avec les policiers municipaux
avec les médiateurs sociaux la
prévention spécialisé dire remettre un
peu des moy comm différents acteurs sur
le terrain quand je vois les forces
d'action républicaine c'est ni plus ni
moins que ce que nous nous connaissons
ce qu'on appelle les conseils locaux de
sécuritéz tout de suite sur une mesure
bon vous m'avez pas répondu sur les
méthodes séparé en 2 jours faut pas y
voir quoi le le grand amphithéâtre de la
Sorbonne aujourd'hui et demain on est à
Chantelou leving c'est c'est il y a deux
jambesés à chant sur le comité inter
pour le social et le sécuritaire on est
effectivement sur peut-être juste un
tout petit mot pour dire que il nous
faut de l'humain au cœur des
organisations et là enfin on va avoir de
l'humain au cœur des organisations je le
réclame depuis longtemps avec un certain
nombre de collègues tant mieux je sais
pas si c'est de l'humain mais en tout
cas il y a une mesure alors peut-être
que on va pas parler que de celle-là
mais forcément elle va être commenté
c'est l'armée l'armée pour encadrer les
jeunes délinquants mineurs Stéphane
Troussel on se souvient de ces Goolen
royal qui prenait ça également Nicolas
Sarkozi en son temps est-ce que c'est le
rôle des militaires est-ce que vous avez
des question sur la mesure est-ce qu'il
s'agirait de de jeunes qui sont
condamnés qui sont en centre éducatif
fermé qu'on sortirait pour leur
apprendre la discipline comment vous
réagissez à cette à cette proposition
franchement tout ça me laisse très
perplexe bon parce que au-delà de ce
qu'on peut penser les uns et les autres
d'éventuellement faire appel à des
militaires est-ce que on pourrait
s'accorder pour dire que un des
problèmes dans notre pays et y compris
d'ailleurs face à des phénomènes de
violence comme ceux auxquels on a
assister il y a aussi une question de
confiance dans l'action publique moi ce
que je voudrais surtout c'est que les
paroles de la la première ministre quel
que soit ce qu'on peut en juger les uns
et les autres elles correspondent à la
réalité de l'action qui vont qui va être
mener dans les prochains mois je vais
vous donner deux exemples la police et
la justice j'entends dire qu'il va y
avoir des nouvelles forces d'action
républicaine très franchement avec
policiers magistrat éducateurs il y a
pas si longtemps que ça dans nos
quartiers on appelait ça des groupes de
traitement locaux de la
délinquence fonction des moyens des
organisations gouvernementales ça existe
ça n'existe plus deuxième chose
j'entends j'ai cru comprendre qu'il y
avait un engagement de président de la
République je sais plus si c'est le
président de la République où le
ministre de l'Intérieur avait employé
l'expression remettre du bleu sur le
terrain avant de venir j'ai appelé mon
ami le maire de Pierre fit sur scène euh
son commissariat c'est le commissariat
de pierrefit stetin la population n'a
pas cessé d'augmenter depuis 25 ans vous
savez la réalité de ces effectif de
police eux en 25 ans ils ont baissé de
25 %. on est passé de 160 dans la
circonscription de police de pierre
filstin à 120 aujourd'hui c'est ça la
réalité par exemple des moyens de la
police 2ème exemple la justice moi je
suis pour qu'il y ait une justice euh
qui prononce des peines adaptées mais
qui prononce des peines et rapides
efficace mais quel est l'état de la
justice aujourd'hui dans notre pays en
particulier dans les territoires comme
les nôtres ou euh n'importe quel
justiciable euh qu'il est commis euh euh
un acte répréhensible ou même euh un
citoyen lambda qui veut faire valoir ses
droits vis-à-vis d'un d'un autre ou qui
par exemple est dans un dans une
procédure familiale de divorce des
comparitiontions immédiates ça vous le
reconnaissez et tout ça on n'est pas
traité de la même manière par exemple en
C saint quand on est de part et d'autre
du périphérique entre la la justice de
proximité dans le 18e arrondissement et
enine s on n'est pas traité de la même
manière donc ce que je voudrais moi
simplement c'est que les paroles qui
quoi qu'on puisse en penser les uns et
les autres c'est que les paroles de la
premierre ministre soit suivi d'un
certain nombre de réalités et la
deuxième remarque surtout que je veux
faire c'est que euh quand même il y a un
éléphant là au milieu de la pièce euh
que visiblement le gouvernement n'a pas
voulu voir c'est ces émeutes elles ne
sont pas nées de nulle part il y a pas
eu spontanément des émeutes il y a eu un
fait générateur de ces émeutes c'est la
mort d'un jeune de 17 ans dans la ville
de nanare et et tout le monde s'est
étonné par exemple de la de la réaction
de la euh de de de l'explosion de de
violence de colère qui s'est exprimé dès
le premier soir et y compris avec des
souvent des des des jeunes très jeunes
moi je considère qu'il y a eu un
phénomène d'identification qu'est-ce
qu'on dit des rapports entre la police
et la population et notamment les plus
jeunes de nos concitoyens rien au al on
va en voir un sujet exprès là-dessus sur
les les rapports police population je
vois que vous avez plein de choses à
dire et peut finalement sur ces mesures
que vous balayez assez rapidement d'un
revers de de de main M Dialo puisque on
parlait euh on est sur du répressif on a
j'ai l'impression que vous êtes pas tout
à fait d'accord sur la question des
militaires ça pour vous c'est c'est que
c'est un c'est de l'affichage voulez pas
commenter ça d'accord il y a il y a
quand même eu énormément et on l'a vu de
mineurs parmi les les hmetiers et pour
le gouvernement Naël n'était qu'un
prétexte ça vous contester cette analyse
là mais bien bien sûr c'est c'est en
fait on ce que ce que disait monsieur
Monsieur Je je souscris tout à fait à ce
qui a été dit juste avant
euh en fait on fait fi de tout tout le
démantelllement des services publics
dans sur nos territoires d' ce ce qui
tient et vous l'avez dit en fait comment
tiennent nos territoires bah grâce à la
cohésion en fait sociale qui existe
entre les différents services de police
services municipaux les associations les
habitants qui ont fait que moi j'étais
au Canada quand ça s'est passé je suis
rentré le le
weekend j'ai j'ai entendu tout ce
qu'avaient fait les gens c'està-dire les
gens les acteurs les hab h vous
TR qui éta au cur qui éta au cœur de nos
quartiers le soir en danger qui se
mettait en danger d'ailleurs au milieu
de la police au milieu des jeunes au
milieu de la violence et cetera et en
fait c'est toute cette force là qu'on a
vu aussi pendant l'épisode covid en fait
on a vu toute cette puissance qu'on a
mais de plus en plus tous les jours là
on parle pas des moyens qu'on va donner
à ces structures qui tous les jours
perdent des moyens c'estàdire que moi
aujourd'hui mon ma ma structure mon
engagement s'appuie sur des volontaes
civiques quand il s'appuyaent il y a
quelques années sur des salariés qui
était formé et cetera euh les
enseignants aujourd'hui on en trouve
plus donc aujourd'hui on prend des
vacataires dans l'éducation nationale
dans la police on a plus de moyens et
cetera moi c'est ça que j'ai envie de
c'est de ça dont j'ai envie de parler et
et et sur les parents juste ça
m'intéresse de vous entendre et sur les
parents moi moi je des parents sont
c'est c'est une explosion de violence
elle arrive suite à un événement qui
nous a tous bouleversé c'est-à-dire que
moi quand j'ai vu la vidéo au Canada sur
mon téléphone j'avais les larmes aux
yeux je comprenais pas je me disais mais
qu'est-ce qui c'est c'est pas possible
que qu'en France aujourd'hui en 2023 un
agent de police puisse tuer un enfant en
fait je me suis dit non pas dans une
démocratie comme la nôtre pas dans une
voilà donc donc qui est annoncé
aujourd'hui pour responsabiliser les
parents avec euh ces stages il y aura
même des peines de travaux d'intérêts
généraux pour les parents qui se
soustraient à leurs devoirs éducatifs
voir des contributions financières hein
pour euh euh les les familles euh dont
dont les les mineurs ont été euh euh
condamnés euh il faudrait que les
parents payent les associations de
victimes vous êtes sur le terrain on va
enfoncer les gens davantage ou pas mais
on sait de quel parents on parle on on
on on se rend compte de de de la
difficulté pour ses parents des fois mè
isolés et cetera d' de de d'élever leurs
enfants dans l'isolement c'est-à-dire
que moi j'ai connu une époque j'ai donc
j'ai grandi au petit à nanter au petit
nanter j'ai connu une époque il y a des
grandes familles où tout le tout tout le
quartier élevit les enfants ça veà dire
on va faire on va faire l'analogie avec
les villages africains peu importe ou ou
les villages dans la Creuse ou en
auverne où tout le monde tout le monde
se connaît tout le monde se connaît tout
le monde élève les enfants et cetera
aujourd'hui on a des familles qui sont
isolé qui demandent de l'aide moi j'ai
il y a des mamans qui qui viennent
frapper là je fais un clin d'œil aussi
au club de prévention qui pouvait être
là ce soir en fait les parents viennent
toquer à la porte de nos structures pour
nous dire j'ai besoin d'aide j'arrive
plus à tenir mon fils je rappelle il y a
quand même dans le dans le plan un
accompagnement justement pour les pour
les maires isolées on est on est
clairement dans un face à face il y a
une demande
d'autorité les stages de
responsabilisation je sais pas comment
ils appellent ça des parents je trouve
qu'on franchit un pas presque
philosophique c'està dire que l'État va
apprendre va même obliger les gens à
apprendre à éduquer leurs parents comme
si on pouvait tout résoudre par un stage
c'est pareil pour le RSA d'ailleurs ah
bah c'est pas grave on va leur faire
faire des stage de 15h à CH vois qu'il y
a un problème on va faire un stage mais
c'est d'un une infantilisation
humiliante quasiment pour les gens euh
et d'ailleurs c'est assez cohérent avec
la ligne du gouvernement puisque l'école
à la maison qui était pour moi quelque
chose de un sas de liberté où les gens
il y avait des contrôles bien sûr où les
gens avaient la possibilité sur simple
déclaration d'éduquer leurs enfants à la
maison avec les programmes de
l'Éducation nationale a été dé facto
supprimé par ce gouvernement puisque
auparavant c'était déclaratif et que
maintenant c'est soumis à autorisation
et globalement c'est plus personne ne
l'obtient et en fait c'est exactement la
même philosophie c'est on ne vous fait
tellement pas confiance que on pense que
vous êtes pas capable ni d'éduquer vos
enfants au sens de l'r uction ni de les
éduquer au sens civil on va vous
apprendre ça avec des
stagesutorité qui est moment où Platon
dit on va on va mettre tous les enfants
ensemble et puis c'est l'État qui va les
qui va les contrôler et parce que les
parce que comme ça au moins r on a bien
compris on vous a pas encore entendu Abd
il y a beaucoup de choses c'est
difficile il y a plein non déjà je crois
que vous vous avez des choses à nous
dire sur le sur le militaire pour vous
c'est pas de l'affichage ça peut marcher
il y a expériences déjà qui sont menées
en France non le militaire on va dire
que moi je j'ai fait mon service
militaire donc j'ai fait l'armée donc
c'est une autre époque et je pense aussi
que la société évolue mais il y a
d'autres dispositifs qui existent comme
les épides parce que vous n'avez pas
vous avez pas parlé de ça les
établissements d'insertion
professionnelle et de d'aide à l'emploi
qui permettent justement à des jeunes
justement qui sont désociabilisés et
d'être dans des structures on va dire
encadré c'est pas forcément militaire
mais on leur réapprend on va dire
l'éducation civique on leur réapprend un
métier et même vous avez des personnes
qui sont en association avec le Pôle
emploi qui qui vont vers ces jeunes et
que clé en main bah ils peuvent les
récupérer mais je veux revenir sur
l'aspect on va dire autoritaire je
dirais pas l'aspect autoritaire moi ce
qui m'intéresse en fait c'est
qu'aujourd'hui bon nombre de Français
bon nombre de personnes qui vivent dans
ces quartiers ce qu'ils veulent en fait
c'est quoi c'est juste simplement
pouvoir rentrer chez eux dans toute
quiétude qui est garant de la sécurité
de ces citoyens c'est on va dire la
police municipale la police nationale
l'état si aujourd'hui pourquoi on arrive
à la responsabilisation des parents
pourquoi on a touché on va dire cette
espèce de sanct tion qui est l'éducation
parentale c'est qu'à un moment donné il
y a eu une défaillance il y a une
défaillance aujourd'hui on peut
s'fusquer du fait que oui mais comment
ça c'estit que l'État met le nez dedans
je suis désolé aujourd'hui c'est que
quand on est père de famille mère de
famille que ce soit monoparental et
cetera aujourd'hui on se doit quand même
de pouvoir éduquer son enfant avec
toutes les difficultés qu'il y a je
pense qu'effectivement il est nécessaire
de se dire que mon enfant n'a pas à être
à 1h 2h du matin dehors tant bien que je
pense que tout le monde était choqué du
fait de voir que il y a eu des des
pillages et tout tout ça et c'est ça il
faut le dire qui qui a été pillé qui a
été brûlé ce sont ces services publics
je vous rappelle encore une fois dans
des quartiers dans des quartiers où il y
a une difficulté et ca donc ça
aujourd'hui quand il y a un service
public en moin c'est justement de on va
dire de un problème de d'expansion
sociale pour ces personnes qui sont en
galère alors Carl olive on va parler de
du lien police population parce que
c'était quand même aussi les origines de
de ce refus d'obtempérer mais la
question de
l'autorité qui doit la résoudre on a
beaucoup dit après les émeutes il y a un
problème d'autorité autorité du
professeur autorité de l'agent du de la
police du respect autorité aussi des
parents est-ce que l'État c'est à Lui
d'essayer de restaurer cette autorité
c'est lui aussi mais pas seulement je
crois que dans cette société il faut
qu'on arrête de de jouer chacun dans son
couloir et pardon mais je reviens sur ce
que je disais sur une réalité du terrain
je pense comme Monsieur Dialo je viens
des quartiers populaires j'ai grandi en
famille nombreuse on était 8 avec une
mixté sociale qu'on vivait sur la dalle
du du du du quartier et on a aucune
difficulté d'abord sur le concept de
base se faire confiance se
responsabiliser sans sans alternative il
faut qu'on soit dans un contrat gagnant
gagnant le contrat gagnant- gagnant
c'est comme dans le sport on a des
règles du jeu simplement dans ce pays on
ne rappelle pas suffisamment les règles
du jeu je vais vous donner un exemple
très concret et qui va rejoindre ce que
disait abdouï monsieur
Kanté pendant le covid on a un sujet de
pouvoir d'achat pour les famille je
décide en tant que maire de poissi mes
collègues élus évidemment ce qu' aur pu
faire monsieur Troussel de de de faire
bénéficier de 30 € de réduction les
familles dont les enfants entre 12 et 17
ans veulent faire une activité sportive
et de 50 € pour une activité culturelle
aller dans un conservatoire de musique à
une condition ce que j'ai appelé le
pouvoir d'achat citoyen qui a un
comportement citoyen et quand à 2h du
matin parce que c'est arrivé mais tout
le monde connaît les règles du jeu un
jeune de 12 ans 2h du matin pète un
abribus sur la voie publque public on
est plus dans le contrat gagnant gagnant
et tout le monde connaît les règles et
donc les parents sont venus qu'est-ce
qu'on a dit qu'est-ce qu'on fait on
suspend on supprime cette mesure là nous
a permis de ne plus avoir du jour au
lendemain de sujet de délinquence mineur
sur la voie donc ça marche pour vous F
juste le bilan je l'ai jamais utilisé en
revanche on a renoué le lien avec la
famille pour ça que je parle d'humain au
cœur des organisations et ça fonctionne
dans le quartier moi je suis pas celui
qui stigmatiser les quartiers
certainement pas en revanche ce matin
j'étais au marché de poissie à borgar
avec des associations de M qui réclam de
l'autorité alors parfois parce qu'elles
sont seules et c'est vrai que là dans
les décisions qui ont été prises par par
le gouvernement je rappelle que c'est
coconstruit c'est-à-dire que c'est aussi
une remontée bien expliqué c'est une
remontée aussi des m qui é alors on va
essayer de voir avec un un reportage de
nos équipes Clément per et Raphael
lzamba comment ça se passe sur le
terrain ce lien entre police et
population ils se sont rend
entre veux etvelin
reportage dans cette voiture personne
n'a oublié les violences urbaines du
début de l'été nous sommes avec la CDI
de Lyon la compagnie départementale
d'intervention de la police nationale ce
sont ces hommes qui ont directement
affronter les hmetiers pour nous en
parler il nous emène sur le plateau
desing
vux c'est une zone un petit peu sensible
forcément où pour travailler certaines
précautions à prendre quand on arrive ce
soir là le tram le tram est bloqué juste
en face de nous par les émetiers et on
est accueilli avec un ensemble de jet
projectile on s'est aperçu queils
étaient de plus en plus nombreux qui
cherchaient à créer une espèce de front
entre guillemets face à nous et tentai
de nous contourner beaucoup de moyens
pyrotechniqu
l'objectif est de casser du flic pour
certains oui on le sait et sur ce genre
d'événement enfin on entend énormément
d'insultes d'insultes de menace de mort
et autres après voilà le dialogue est
quand même assez restreint une fois que
la situation est dégradé à ce
point-là un dialogue dans l'impasse
c'est aussi le constat que font beaucoup
d'habitants des cités de l'agglomération
lyonnaise oublié jaffarench est un
militant associatif dans le quartier
sensible du mat du taureau àau envelin
il côtoi les jeunes au quotidien et
tente à leur côté de mieux comprendre
les mécanismes à l'origine des
tensions si on vous pose la question
aujourd'hui vous avez vécu comment le là
les derniers événements c'est c'est
inadmissible ce qui s'est passé à Paris
c'est c'est c'est c'est quelque chose
d'or du commun le le fait que na é fait
que le policier tire sur na à bout
portant parce que je me suis dit ça il a
17 ans ça aurait pu être nous ça aurait
pu être moi lui lui moi j'étais pour les
émeutes parce que entre la police qui
ici qui nous fait des bavures à chaque
fois qu'il nous voit qui nous qui nous
insulte qui se moque de nous entre entre
ça et entre la mort de de de Naël bah
moi j'ai trouvéis que il méritait la
relation avec avec l'institution elle
est pas stable ou donc du coup faut la
recréer faut recréer un quand vous dites
l'institution bah ça peut être
l'institution état l'institution police
l'institution ville tout ça en fait
c'est ça qu'on peut police police
faudrait renouer après ça vare compé ça
va être compliqué de des deux côtés du
coupou ouais bah oui des deux côtés des
deux côtés c'est sûr 4 mois après les
événements les pls sont loin d'être
cicatrisé Stéphane trousel c'est par
rayon c'est une Saint-Denis cette
défiance je vis dire d'abord dans ce sur
ce plateau il n'y a que des gens qui euh
vivent habitent sont élu exercent des
responsabilités dans les quartiers
populaires je suis né à Saint-Denis je
suis élu de la scène Saint-Denis je vis
à la cour neuve depuis ma naissance j'y
vis encore J a fait toute ma scolarité
l'insécurité quotidienne les violences
les dégradations je les condamne je les
ai condamnés pendant ces cette période
d'émeute parce que je sais que ce sont
d'abord les habitants de ces quartiers
populaires qui ont eu à subir ces
dégradations qui on à subir ces
violences qui ont subir les conséquences
donc que les choses soient très claires
pour autant je considère que encore une
fois le gouvernement ne peut pas faire
abstraction parce que sinon je ne vois
ce qui demain empêcherait qu'il y ait
une nouvelle explosion de vol violence
après un fait aussi tragique que CELI on
verra peut-être que demain ce volet de
discrimination sera prvu à
chantelouing qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire
parce que on les entend je on a
l'impression que le divorce il est
profond et durable exactement la
République française elle tient en
particulier par ses services publics par
l'éducation la police la justice c'est
ça qui nous fait tenir ensemble moi je
je ne peux pas supporter qu'une partie
importante de la population je pense au
plus jeunes je pense en particulier aux
jeunes issus de ce quartier soit ne soit
pas dans cette relation de confiance et
donc je regrette que depuis 4 mois ce
débat là n''est pas pu avoir lieu je ne
dis pas que je ne dis pas que j'ai la
solution je ne dis pas et je ne veux
accuser personne enfin quand pourquoi
par exemple à la pourquoi la formation
des policiers dans notre pays elle est
de 12 mois quand elle est de 36 mois en
Allemagne
pourquoi à la suite que il n'y a pas les
mêmes statistiques en zone gendarmerie
qu'en zone police vous demandz
aussippliation Demez la suppression
deette pas la suppression je demande
qu'on évalue les situations par exemple
et je je pense que sur les questions
relation police population il y a des
choses qui ont été faites il faut
regarder ce qui marche aussi ce qui a
été fait généralement on parle de ce qui
est mauvais mais Gén il y a des choses
qui ont été faites notamment sur la
transparence en elle-même notamment sur
les contrôles d'identité lesôles étaé la
généralisation des caméras piéton on en
parle pas de ça
35 sont obligatoires maintenant sur les
sur les interventions et ça on n parle
pas et sur aussi le fait qu'on peut
saisir aussi directement l'IGPN l'IGPN
quand on parle que I c'est une instance
qui est des fois malheureusement
méconnue et quand je vais des fois dans
ces structures pour parler aux jeunes là
des fois ils les connaissent pas et
quand je leur montre que à partir de
leur smartphone elle est soumise à
beaucoup de critiques
l'inspect
parmepp depuis quand même depuis poli
depis 201 quand même depuis les
manifestations de la jusqu'à aujourd'hui
chaque année l'pn à la vue du public
établi des rapports d'activité des
sanctions qui sont émises en faire des
policiers qui ont commis des erreurs et
encore une fois nous sommes un des corps
les plus contrôlés de toutes les
administration et juste pour finir aussi
sur le dialogue police population je
viens je viens avec un discours de
vérité moi quand je vais voir ces jeunes
là je peux vous dire que quand on leur
explique nos actions il faut aussi de
notre responsabilité en tant que
policier d'expliquer nos actions pour
être mieux compris des fois on fait
souvent face à des jeunes qui ont une
méconnaissance des institutions qus ont
une méconnaissance du mot République et
c'est ça qu'il faut aujourd'hui parler à
ces jeunes là il faut aussi accepter
alors le parler c'était peut-être la
police de proximité mais elle existe
déjà la police de proximité si vous
voulez très très vite la police de
proximité c'est quoi on n parle pas on
parle jamais elle a été supprimée la
police municipale aujourd'hui et je me
satisfais que la ministre la première
ministre aujourd'hui met en avant ces
actions là parce que depuis longtemps
qui fait la proximité c'est les police
municipales oui ou non B qui peut
imaginer que mon collègue maire de
Pierre fit qui a de très faibles
recettes fiscales peut créer comme à
levois Peret une police municipale de
proximité qui va jouer ce rôle de
contact au quotidien donc ça ça crée des
inégalités suément dit le député olive
le souci c'est que au niveau du
financement c'est que c'est dû au fait
au au au à la multitude de dégradations
et quand vous avez des dégradations dans
C certaines communes difficile aussi de
pouvoir financer cel alors Carle les
vous vous êtes vous avez été longtemps
maire aussi à poissie on est on dit
beaucoup coup en fait que dans les
quartiers les policiers n'arrivent que
lorsqu'il y a un acte de délinquence qui
a été commis une infraction qui a été
commise ils arrivent ils ne sont jamais
là quand tout va bien si j'ose dire si
on donne plus de pouvoir à la police
municipale c'est le cas alors je sais
pas si vous vous trouverez ça bien mais
avec les annonces aujourd'hui le
policier municipal pourra accomplir des
actes de police judiciaire sous le
contrôle du parquet ouis mais je vais
vous dire cette cette idée-là elle sort
pas du chapeau he il y a pas de garci
Mor dans la pièce hein c'est encore une
fois les maires qui notamment début
juillet à l'Élysée ont notamment
manifesté cette possibilité là et moi je
vais vous dire j'en suis fort satisfait
la police municipale en est fort
satisfaite j'ai eu le le directeur de la
police c'est l'ériie qui paye la police
municipale elle en a les moyens bien ben
c'est la mquip moi je j'ai la scène
Saint-Denis est un département pauvre
qui obtient aussi beaucoup de subsides
sur la solidarité inter départemental et
le les fonds de solidarité et tant mieux
mais après c'est effectivement une
volonté moi quand je suis arrivé en 2014
j'ai perdu nombre d'effectifs de la
police nationale je suis pas le Valois
Peret mais j'ai considéré que la
première des libertés c'était aussi de
pouvoir être protégé sereinement la
police municipale à poissi on a
multiplié quasiment par 20 le nombre
d'effectifs pas pour être avec avec une
matraque sur la tête c'est qu'on est
dans la prévention en revanche on TR
donznous le nombre d'habitants il y a
combien de et d'officiers de police
municipale 44 aujourd'hui simplement
demain la police municipale on va vous
contrôler vous êtes avec un un
stupéfiant vous consommez quelque chose
de dé ux on la police municipale va
pouvoir verbaliser ce qu'elle ne peut
pas faire aujourd'hui aujourd'hui elle
interpelle en flagrant délit elle
l'amène à la police à la police
nationale je pense encore une fois il
faut et je suis d'accord avec vous c'est
pas quand le mal est fait qu'il faut
effectivement c'est pas c'est pas les
émeutes derrière on on va voir les
maires et il faut absolument que la
valorisation de nos quartiers
l'insertion et on en parlera demain au
Conseil interministériel de de la lutte
contre les discriminations les
l' des jees au travers du sport il y a
des choses qui sont aussi simples à
faire dans dans les quartiers je vous
donne juste de l'ouverture des des
écoles après la fermeture des des
devoirs pourquoi serait pas ouvert
pourquoi on n'ouvrirait pas les préos
c'est possible ça c'est pas compliqué
pourquoi on demanderait pas au bailleurs
dans les quartiers de pouvoir mettre à
disposition un pied d'immeuble pour
faire ce qu'on appelle des tierslieux
éducatifs la c'est des initiatives
locales du maire
he pas du maire du ENF pas seulement du
maire du maire sur Madame du maire du du
bailleur et ou ce que je veux dire c'est
que vous avez pas besoin de l'État pour
faire ça c'est l'initi une volonté on
peut pas tout attendre de l'État mais
juste Madou Dialo qui a pas beaucoup
parlé justement je le rejoindre je va lu
passer la balle c'est justement mettre
aussi en avant aussi les associations de
quartiers qui sont eux les les acteurs
principals justement de de de C de de
ces quartiers là pour terminer ce débat
qu'est-ce que vous vous attendez en tant
qu'acteur de terrain sur cette ce lien
entre la police et la population est-ce
qu'on peut le réparer déjà selon vous
est-ce que c'est possible moi moi je
suis non seulement convaincu qu'on peut
qu'on peut le réparer mais en plus je
suis convaincu que la le plus plus large
de la population dans nos quartiers a
pas de problème avec la police c'està
dire que même quand on regarde les
émeutes il suffit de regarder le nombre
de de gamins qu'il y avait dans la rue
je veux dire nous au petit Nanterre il y
a 8000 habitants il y avait pas 8000
habitants dans dehors le soir une
centaine de de de gamins donc pareil
quand on parle de responsabilité des
familles de truc je veux dire la plupart
des familles ont tout fait pour garder
leurs gamins des fois des fois cétait
difficile des fois moi j'ai des des
mamans qui m'ont dit j'ai du mal à à
contenir mon enfant qui était pas qui
est pas du tout quelqu'un d'agité qui
est pas du tout mais qui était en colère
par rapport à l'identification qu'il av
la police qu'est-ce qu'on pourrait lace
reconstruire pour que la défiance cesse
pour moi la police c'est en fait c'est
dans un continuum où en fait on a pu
comment on peut mettre en place un
travail une ingénierie du travail
communautaire sur c'est que la politique
de la ville plutôt que de donner un peu
de s à la police municipale un peu de
truc on travaille sur une cohérence de
tous les actes
les acteurs socio-éducatifs qui
comprennent des commerçants des acteurs
associatifs des services de l'État les
services publics en général et qu'on
travaill ensemble à des réponses
communes cohérentes sur le sur les
territoires la police parmi d'autres moi
l'école m'inquiète m'interroge plus que
la police la pole c'est des pour moi
c'est quand ils interviennent on en a
besoin ils interviennent de temps en
temps pctuellement mais c'est j'attends
l'universel pour moi c'est l'éducation
donc c'est l'école et quand je vois
l'état de l'école tout on voit voilà le
laboratoire il est local c'est surtout
ça qu'on re c'est ça je v quand Mme
revenir un touttit peu sur la question
de la police je je pense qu'on a une
question par exemple des contrôles
d'identité moi je vis depuis 53 ans dans
le département de la scène Saint- à La
Courneuve j'ai deux garçons je n'ai
jamais fait l'objet d'un contrôle alors
justement sur ce que dit le Conseil
d'État
récemment par contre mes copains qui
s'appellent Mahamadou ou ou Mohamed ils
le sont régulièrement IC compris oui
mais c'est pas moi qui l'invente la
défenseur des dro la Défenseur des
droits Défenseur des droits en 2023 par
qu'il est là le débat personnes vous
avez 20 fois plus que de
risqueés est revenu làdessus pour dire
que la police française n pas race peut
AR qu'il des actes comment dir répréensi
mais qui sont sannés réités statisti qui
ont été montré par les associations
notamment par les testings on verra
demain parce que normalement c'est
demain cette question de la lutte contre
les discriminations on verra puisque
vous avez choisi d'avancer sur de
manches de jambes sur de jours ce qui
sera dit sur ce sur ce sujetl àing on
s'arrête là merci beaucoup merci d'être
venu débattre sur LCP vous restez avec
moi Gaspar Kenig dans une dizaine de
minutes les partis prix de nous
affranchis ce soir le regard de yel
Goose sur les négociations en coulisse
attention à la surenchère sur la loi
immigration celui de Vincent euug jeux
sur l'offensive terrestre à Gaza qui a
commencé d'une certaine manière elle
nous dira et puis elamondin Gava de quoi
nous parlez-vous dans Bourbon Express ce
soir on parle de l'IVG dans la
Constitution c'est pour bientôt à tout à
l'heure les amis mais d'abord on va
plonger dans les profondeurs de l'humus
votre roman Gaspar Kenig il est à la
fois réjouissant un peu terrifiant à la
fois c'est un livre sur les vers de
terre c'est un livre sur la crise
climatique où l'on voit s'affronter deux
amis deux ingénieurs de visions un
bourgeois idéaliste qui choisit la
désobéissance civile et un fils du
peuple non chalent qui va choisir la
gros business la suite dans l'invitation
d'élène Bonduel et on en parle tous les
deux juste
après
si on vous invite Gaspar kque c'est pour
une plongée sous terre pour le moins
originale une ondulation au rythme des
ver de terre aujourd'hui on prédit les
comètes de manière enfin les étoiles
enfin tout ça de manière extrêmement
précise il y beaucoup de gens qui
travaillent là-dessus on investit dans
des télescopes extraordinaires la
science du sol bizarrement a été assez
peu
exploré alors Gaspar kenic vous le
philosophe essayiste libéral et
romancier vous vous écartez cette fois
de la politique pour vous consacrer à
une passion récente dans votre nouveau
roman humus humus cette fine couche de
la surface de la Terre dans laquelle
vivent plus de 5000 espèces de
lombrique vous imaginez l'histoire de
deux étudiants ingénieurs en agronomie
une amitié nouée sur le plateau de
sacelet pendant un cours sur les vers de
terre et ils vont y consacrer leur
carrière leur vie même
le verre de terre pourrait devenir notre
meilleur allié il est possible de le
réintroduire dans les sols par
inoculation mieux encore on peut le
mettre au travail pour traiter les
déchets de l'humanité Kevin fils
d'ouvrier agricole choisit la voix du
capitalisme vert en créant sa start-up
de vermicomposteur industriel pour trier
les déchets Arthur enfant de la
bourgeoisie décide lui de bifurquer il
pourrait être l'un de ses étudiants
déserteur
d'agroparitech nous ne voyons pas les
ravages écologiques et sociaux comme des
enjeux ou des défis auxquels nous
devrions trouver des solutions en tant
qu'ingénieur j'ai rejoint le mouvement
les soulèvements la terre pour lutter
contre l'accaparement des terres
agricoles et leur bétonnisation partout
en France yresse de la politique et de
la sphère médiatique pour Kevin retour à
la terre des ancêtres et à l'activisme
cololo pour Arthur humus en lis pour le
Gon courour et le prix renaudo est un
roman d'apprentissage
l'écologie au cœur de la réalité sociale
économique et politique alors nous avons
une question pour vous Gaspar conique la
radicalisation de la contestation
écologique est-elle
[Musique]
inévitable réponse gpar réponse
effectivement dans le roman je mets en
scène on va dire on va dire c'est pas
tout à fait la fin mais presque la fin
le moment où le héros qui fait partie de
sa génération qui est pas tout à fait
bifurqueur derilleurs parce qu'il
regarde les fur sur scène et lui il y va
pas parce que j'ai voulu que j'ai pas
voulu mettre en scène des militants euh
qui sont forcément un peu à la marche
quand même de leur génération j'ai voulu
mettre en scène des héros qui partagent
la conscience écologique moyenne de de
ceux qui sont autour d'eux et puis après
la vie fait son travail et qui font des
choix parfois un peu malgré exactement
parfois parfois parce qu'il y a une
fille parfois parce qu'il y a une
opportunité bon la radicalisation voà et
voilà et donc à la fin on y va forcément
ce héros qui est euh disons un peu dans
les mouvements d'aujourd'hui qui sont
quand même je rappelle des mouvements
fondés sur la désobéissance civile et
qui sont aujourd'hui très responsables
voire très très sage c'est même étonnant
de voir à quel point notre jeunesse est
sage quelque part on va mettre de la
peinture sur les tableaux la compote sur
les tableaux en s'assurant qu'il y a une
vitre on se colle dans la rue en
s'assurant que la colle puisse être
décollée par la police donc vous la
redoutez pas cette radicalisation vous
la souhaitezendez attendez et euh là on
est dans le mouvement de désobéissance
civil qui est classique dans la la
philosophie de l'écologie depuis
henry-david taureau h et mon héros dans
le livre il est rattrapé par la
génération d'après donc là on se
projette dans 5 10 ans génération qui
est aujourd'hui voilà qui qui
aujourd'hui qui est aujourd'hui à peine
ad dos qui lui dit mais attendez là tous
vos trucs de désobéissance civile sympa
pour éveiller les consciences ça ne
marche pas donc nous maintenant on est
là pour prendre le pouvoir on est des
vrais radicaux on fait de l'action
directe et donc eux ils sont ils sont
pas du tout là pour convaincre ils sont
là pour prendre le pouvoir
éventuellement par les armes par la
violence et j'étais très frappé dans les
manifestations du weekend dernier h h
pour la 69 h je suis très pour c'est
manif je trouve que cette a69 est
absurde et que c'est c'est c'est normal
la désobéissance civil fait partie de
nos
démocrati mais dedans il y avait une une
femme qui portait un T-shirt avec marqué
action directe et on voit bien qu'on est
aujourd'hui euh dans les débuts de
quelque chose de beaucoup plus radical
dans le mouvement écolo qui a commencé
avec la publication en 2019 de comment
sa botter un pipeline euh qu' l' c'est
la question de la violence oui qu' a dit
bon bah maintenant on a plus le temps et
donc c'est l'action directe l'action
directe je rappelle dans les années 70
c'est d'un groupe terroriste c'est du
vrai terrorisme c'est-à-dire que là
c'est des bombes c'est des kidnappings
c'est des assassina on en est pas du
tout là aujourd'hui si ils n'ont pas le
sentiment d'être entendu écouté et
qu'ils ont le sentiment enfin et que
nous avons quelque part le sentiment que
l'urgence est telle qu'on ne peut pas se
permettre de perdre encore 50 ans
éveiller les consciences je ne dis pas
que je le souhaite mais il y a une
certaine logique compris romanesque dans
le livreou aller jusqu'au bout c'est ça
qui est intéressant c'est parce que vous
donnez au fond leur chance à vos deux
héros un peu à égalité sans vraiment
choisir il y a chez Gaspar kque du
Arthur et du Kevin d'une certaine
manière vous êtes le pragmatique un peu
non chalent qui va devenir une star de
l'agrobusiness avec le ver
vermicompostage c'est ça le nom et une
certaine manière vous êtes aussi
l'idéaliste jusqueau bouthiste
exactement c'est ça exactement et le
livre et c'est tout à fait ça et quand
les gens me disent mais mais alors Zek
qu'est-ce que tu pense et ca je dis mais
si je le savais si j'avais une solution
pour sauver la planète j'aurais écrit un
essai j'aurais pas écrit un roman et
j'écris un roman précisément parce que
c'est un sujet d'abord qui me touche et
m'angoisse beaucoup mais c'est un sujet
tellement complexe que j'ai voulu
plonger deux héros idéalistes dans le
monde d'aujourd'hui tel qu'il est avec
toutes ces contraintes sociales
économiques agronomiques administratives
juridiquees pour mettre leurs idéaux à
l'épreuve du réel et puis voir ce qui se
passe comment ça chemine et après et pu
en poussant jusqu'au bout leur logique
parce qu'il y en a un qui se radicalise
dans la révolution l'autre qui bah
finalement lève des fonds dans la
silicone vallée donc je vais jusqu'au
bout des deux logiques savoir rester
voilà est-ce qu'ils peuvent rester amis
est-ce qu'il peuvent se retrouver alors
elle vous est venue d'O cette passion
pour les lombriques parce que c'est
quand même pas hyper sexy à la base un
verre de terre ah mais alors ça d'abord
il y a des scènes des scènes de
copilation des ver de terre dans le
livre une peur de sensualité dans ce
ououi mais en plus le ver de terre se
ruit se colle l'un à l'autre de
manière sans sans bouger voyez sans
mouvement de manière très tendre ils
élaborent tout un mucus puis c
hermesaphrodites enfin c'est tout à fait
passionnant euh et puis c'est ils sont
dans la terre c'est le magma de la terre
c'est une forme d'hermaphroditisme
original quelque chose de très sensuel
hein dans la terre d'ailleurs la terre
on reconnaît qu'elle est bonne quand on
la sent parce qu'on a en nous un vieil
instinct qui nous fait reconnaître une
bonne terre parce qu'une bonne terre
sent bon euh et donc comment m'est venue
l'idée euh c'est vrai que vous êtes
aujourd'hui en Normandie voilà et donc
j'ai un j'ai j'ai alors vous j'aiz plus
vous potagez vous je potage euh alors je
potage c'est un bien grand parce que si
vous voyez mon mon potager vous
rigoleriez mais s'il y a quand même
beaucoup d'erreurs de débutants mais
enfin bon je m'y essaye et j'ai une très
bonne terre j'ai hérité de gens qui qui
qui travaillent en bio et donc je vois
ces ver de terre je les vois je les vois
je les regarde je m'aperçois à quel
point ils sont charmants divers ils ont
des couleurs différentes des tailles
différentes ils se comportent
différemment il y en a qui se recroquent
V il y en a qui s'allongent il y en a
qui rentrent dans la terre il y a de
tout faut comprendre quand même parce
que tout le monde ne sait pas à quel
point ces milliers d'espèces sont
indispensables à la vie humaine voà sans
eux tout s'écroule parce que c'est très
documenté aussi ce rom voilà et donc
j'ai commencé mais à titre comme ça
personnel avant d'avoir l'idée de de
d'intégrer ça à ce roman euh
d'initiation euh j'ai commencé à me
documenter sur le verre de terre mais
comme ça euh alors c'est bien parce
qu'on fait assez vite le tour de la
bibliographie c'est d'ailleurs le seul
domaine où on arrive à la fin de youtube
il y a 27 vidéos puis après ça s'arrête
il y a plus rien euh mais on découvre
des choses absolument passionnante
notamment que bon Darwin euh a le
premier conceptualisé le rôle du verre
de terre comme laboureur de la terre hm
hm et a écrit ce qui a été redit par un
rapport scientifique il y a 3 semaines
que le verre de terre est l'animal le
plus important pour la vie sur Terre et
pourquoi parce qu'en fait c'est lui avec
ses amis les champignons les
microbactéries dans le sol c'est lui qui
transforme la mort en vie c'est ça le
sol c'est des feuilles mortes qui
tombent des animaux qui meurent et tout
ça est retravaillé de redécomposé en
petits nutriments en petits éléments
biogènes qui sont ensuite repris par les
racines des plantes et c'est et c'est ça
le cycle et donc et et puis les ver de
terre creusent des galeries les galeries
permettent de structurer les sols de
drainer l'eau d'éviter les glissements
de terrain et dans un sol qui est
cultivé disons je dirais maintenant à
l'ancienne avec des méthodes dures de la
Bour profonde beaucoup d'intran chimique
en conventionnel et bien vous avez plus
de verre de terre petit à petit vous
n'avez plus de galerie donc le sol
est parfitement à quel point sans
la vie sur Terre s'arrête donc c'est
fondamental et en plus pardon homme
vient de humus émologiquement et
bibliquement et quelque part ne pas
prendre soin du sol c'est au sens propre
être inhumain magnifique démonstration
vous avez complètement changé de vie
Gaspar Kenig non on a l'impression vous
qui voyagez énormément vous qui étiez un
grand défenseur de
l'autonomie
individuel vous êtes installé c'est vrai
en Normandie et et vous êtes sédentaire
aujourd'hui très sédent racontez-moi
cette nouvelle vie parce que c'est vrai
qu'on on vous trouve un peu en parfois
enfin en décalage avec la vie d'avant
pas forcément contadiction mais alors
d'abord il y a pas eu de rupture brutale
ça s'est fait petit à petit
le voyage que j'ai fait à cheval à
travers l'Europe m'a m'a plus changé que
ce que j'avais imaginé en fait quand je
suis revenu je suis bah finalement on
reprend la vie d'avant et puis en fait
non il y a beaucoup de choses qui sont
voilà beaucoup de manièrees de vivre qui
ont changé c'est vrai que je voyage
quasiment plus ENF j'ai pas pris la
viande depuis 2 ans et demi aussi un peu
faut le dire par conviction je
m'interdis pas de le prendre un jour
mais il y a eu un déclic particulier non
mais c'est c'est non il y a pas de
déclic c'est progressif mais là où je
trouve j'aiu enfin j'ai j'ai j'ai
j'ai réfléchi à tous mes livres
précédents il y en a pas un que je
renirai et je trouve qu'il y a quand
même une connexion très profonde entre
cet amour de la liberté la liberté
individuelle que j'ai toujours vous
l'avez vu en plateau là dès qu'ils ont
parlé de stage éducation là ça y est je
retrouve mon mois d'avant oUI NON à
l'infantilisation voilà exactement mais
il y a un lien très profond entre la
liberté et la nature et il y a lien très
profond aussi entre l'écologie politique
et la décentralisation l'idée qu'on est
responsable de son territoire ou de son
terroir qu'on voit les conséquences de
ces actes que c'est en expérimentant de
manière autonome en locale que petit à
petit on va améliorer la situation
plutôt que de faire des grands plans à
partir de l'État que la transformation
écologique elle est avant tout
existentielle individuelle que Sant des
des minuscules gestes comme un
vermicomosteur sur votre balcon que
petit à petit vous comprenez plein de
choses et que vous finissez par par
évoluer et que c'est à travers ce ce
souci ouais c'est passionnant parce
qu'on vous sent très engagé oui alors
c'est aussi un peu une une satire une
férroce Sare social c'est important pour
vous que le que le bourgeois Arthur
celui qui est bien né devienne le
révolutionnaire le jusque bouhiste celui
au contraire le fils de la fromagère
alors lui bascule dans le capitalisme
vert d'abord c'est aussi un artifice
romanes parce que chacun arrive en
candide dans un milieu qu'il ne connaît
pas et le regarde donc avec des yeux
ingénus et ça permet à l'écrivain
d'exercer ensuite la Sayre sur les deux
milieux d'ailleurs parce que Kevin quand
il est proché dans le monde des start-up
au début il fait plein de maladresse il
comprend pas bien pourquoi tous ces gens
parlent avec des anglicismes et puis
Arthur quand il arrive dans son champ
néorural convaincu il dit ouais moi je
vais je vais travailler à la FAU à
l'ancienne alors il regarde des vidéos
sur YouTube pour manier la FAU il arrive
pas il se
blesse TR mon des chôurs il non ça fait
du carbone le dé chômeurs puis à la fin
évidemment pr des chômeurs euh donc j'ai
voulu d'abord que tout le monde en
prenne pour son grade hein il y a pas
les gentils d'un côté les méchants de
l'autre au fond la nature humaine quel
que soient les milieux c'est un peu
toujours la même avec ses vis s vertus
c'est personnages extraordinaires c'est
salot c'est collabo enfin bon c'est donc
j'ai voulu mettre ça un peu en miroir
aussi et effectivement permettre à
chacun de ces deux personnages de se
transformer et de petit à petit se
laisser apper en fait par des
convictions nouvelles donc Arthur au
début quand il quand il quand il
retourne retourne à la terre il fait ça
parce qu'il a dit ça à une fille alors
il a un peu pris dans dans son propre
dans son propre imaginaire finalement la
fille le largue et puis il reste et puis
puis petit à petit il se convint
lui-même et puis à la fin il devient
complètement radical Kevin lui aussi il
se laisse un peu porter et puis il y a
ce truc de d'entreprise de
vermicompostage qui arrive et puis petit
à petit ça devient espèce de phénomène
ouais ça le dépasse complètement voilà
et qui qui qui me permet aussi de
décrire les travers du capitalisme
contemporain et notamment du fait que le
capitalisme contemporain repose beaucoup
sur l'imaginaire on pense que c'est un
monde rationnel d'homoconomicus qui font
des comptes mais pas du tout faut faire
des pitch faut séduire des investisseurs
faut même on exige même plus
desentreprises rentabl et il y a
derrière souvent beaucoup de fraudes et
j'ai vraiment d'ailleurs cette
entreprise sur terranos absolument on
retrouve d'ailleurs un certain nombre de
vos thèmes la lutte contre
l'administration machine à broyer le le
Arthur il a des problèmes de RSA qu'on
lui retire enfin on retrouve le Gaspar
kening mais c'est quand même assez
différent hein et c'est peut-être pour
ça d'ailleurs que vous l'aurez le
concours on verra ça en tout cas bonne
chance vous restez avec moi c'est
l'heure d'accueillir nos nos affranchis
pour leur parti prix ils vont vous faire
réagir on les accueille tout de suite et
il AG de France
chef du service politique éditorialiste
bienvenue Vincent UG également grand
reporter chroniqueur dans cette émission
sur l'international on commence par
Bourbon Express comme chaque soir
l'histoire du jour à l'Assemblée c'est
Elsa mondingaba qui nous la raconte
bonsoir Elsa bonsoir je vais vous parler
de l'inscription de l'IVG dans la
Constitution selon nos informations le
calendrier s'accélère le gouvernement
pourrait déposer un projet de loi dans
les prochaines semaine alors c'est pas
nouveau c'est pas une surprise c'est un
engagement du chef de l'État il l'a dit
il y a quelques quel semaines lors du
65e anniversaire de la Constitution il
l'avait déjà promis en mars dernier lors
de l'hommage à Giselle Alimi Giselle
Alimi par ses mots avait fait changer la
loi je veux aujourd'hui que la force de
ce message nous aide à changer notre
Constitution afin d'y graver la liberté
des femmes à recourir à l'interruption
volontaire de
grossesse pour assurer solennellement
que rien ne pourra entraver ou défaire
ce qui sera ainsi irréversible j'ai
exprimé mon souhait le 8 mars dernier
que nous puissions trouver un texte
accordant les points de vue entre
l'Assemblée nationale et le Sénat et
permettant de convoquer un congrès à
Versailles je souhaite que ce travail de
rapprochement des points de vue
reprennent pour aboutir dès que possible
et dès que possible Myriam bah ça
pourrait être dans les prochaines
semaines alors il y a une raison
politique à cette accélération alors
évidemment la première raison politique
bah c'est de faire ce qu'on dit mais il
y a une autre raison c'est que le 30
novembre ici à l'Assemblée c'est la
niche la journée d'initiative
parlementaire du groupe de la France
insoumise et les insoumis ils ont déjà
inscrit une proposition loi pour
constitutionnaliser l'IVG réinscrit plôt
puisque le texte on s'en souvient en
novembre dernier avait déjà été adopté à
une très large majorité ici à
l'Assemblée nationale le 30 novembre ça
pourrait être donc une occasion en or
pour Mathilde pano et ses troupes de
rappeler que la promesse du gouvernement
et bien n'est toujours pas tenue ce
risque d'une tribune politique il a été
év évidemment identifié au gouvernement
aussi dans la majorité Sylvain Maillard
le président du groupe Renaissance se
dit favorable au dépôt d'un projet de
loi avant donc fin novembre fin novembre
on verra ça on va suivre ça évidemment
cette option est-ce qu'elle elle
satisfait tous les camps le gouvernement
mais aussi les insoumis oui et plus
globalement bien tous ceux qui
souhaitent voir l'IVG inscrit dans la
Constitution pourquoi parce que si c'est
une proposition de loi qui est adoptée
elle entraîne un référendum et ça en
fait personne n'en veut personne ne veut
rouvrir le débat et entendre des
positions défavorables à l'avortement
tout le monde donc préfère cette
solution d'un projet de loi d'un texte
du gouvernement puisque là c'est la
réunion des parlementaires le Congrès
assemblée Sénat le dernier congrès
c'était en 2018 il y avait pas eu de
vote il' y avait eu une déclaration du
Président de la République mais donc un
nouveau Congrès nous attends peut-être
dans les prochaines ou à Versailles
avant Noël pour inscrire le droit ou la
liberté d'avorter parce qu'il faut
absolument d'accord sur les mots il faut
la garantir Gaspar Kenig pour pour les
femmes cette cette liberté euh ben cette
liberté elle elle existe me semble-t-il
en France elle existe mais vous savez
qu'elle est menacée dans certains pays
alors constitutionnaliser cette cette
liberté ou ce droit d'accord mais enfin
le combat prioritaire c'est que des
groupes qui
voudraient renoncer et la remettre en
cause d'ailleurs qui je crois n'existe
pas trop dans l'espace politique
français ne prennent pas le pouvoir
ouais on sait Pasin on sait pas les
menaces d'aujourd'hui ou d'hier sont
peut-être celles de demain en toutous
les cas on va vous faire réagir à
l'immigration présent avec yel Goze ce
projet de loi est toujours pas au à
l'Assemblée il arrive il arrive au Sénat
début novembre on en parle on en reparle
vous nous dites attention à la
surenchère ouis c'est typiquement le
texte sur lequel Emmanuel Macron peut
nourrir des regrets de ne pas avoir su
décrocher une majorité absolue au
législative l'an dernier la loi
immigration ça fait 10 mois 10 mois
maintenant qu'au gouvernement on
s'arrache les cheveux pour trouver la la
bonne rédaction qui permettrait de
l'adopter sans passer par le 493
rappelez-vous la formule de Gérald Manin
on sera gentil avec les gentils méchant
avec les méchants mieux expulsé d'un
côté mieux intégré de l'autre on est
enfin on était à l'imparfait dans la
quintessence du macronisme le
dépassement par l'équilibre gauche-doite
et pourquoi alors vous parlez au passé
parle au passé parce que le risque avec
ces lois immigration la 29e en 30 ans
c'est qu'elles sont hyper sensibles à
l'actualité au moindre drame vous avez
les oppositions qui les plus dures qui
monent au créneau pour faire monter les
enchères avec des mesures plus radicales
encore dans la foulée de l'assassinat du
professeur Dominique Bernard c'est la
ligne politique suivie par la droite les
républicains qui conditionne leur vote à
la suppression de cet article 3 du
projet de loi article 3 c'est celui qui
régularise les sans papiers pour les
métiers anention alors depuis on assiste
à quoi à un marchandage sans fin c'est
d'abord Gérald armmanin la semaine
dernière qui qui se dit prêt à
l'aménager cet article 3 pourquoi pas
par une simple circulaire puis c'est le
Parisien mardi qui nous apprend
qu'Élisabeth borne elle aussi aurait
tenu ce discours lors d'un dîner avec le
chef de fil des sénateurs de droite LR
Bruno rotaillot scandale sur l'aile
gauche de la majorité démenti formel de
la première ministre l'article 3 n'est
pas à vendre sauf qu'à la fin
franchement tout est brouillé plus
personne n'y comprend plus rien je sais
pas qui arrive à suivre alors qu'on a
même pas commencé l'examen équation
infernale plus le gouvernement tend la
main à droite et plus il se met en
minorité sur sa gauche et pour
compliquer l'affaire savoir qu'au Sénat
centriste et LR ne pensent pas la même
chose et contre députés LR et sénateur
LR il y a même pas de cohérence non plus
alors plus que personne n'y voit clair
est-ce que vous vous avez la solution
sortons de de ce labyrinthe
parlementaire pour revenir au fait à
l'essentiel ce que le C une autre
chambre la 3ème conseil économique
social environnemental a fait mardi
après-midi lors d'une table ronde sur
l'immigration économique dans dans
l'indifférence générale sans elle sans
cette immigration économique la France
subira la bombe démographique avec les
départs en retraite or la
réindustrialisation va nécessiter de
pourvoir presque un millions d'emplois
d'ici à 2030 comment est-ce qu'on fait
est-ce que c'est un fardeau
l'immigration leocde nous dit que les
immigrés rapportent plus en France qu'il
ne coûte aux finances publiques
l'article 3 consiste donc à sortir de
l'hypocrisie et il ne tient qu'à la
société civile au syndicat et au
patronat bien silencieux de rappeler ces
évidences au plus démagau de nos députés
quelques secondes pour réagir je
voudrais rappeler la réflexion de
Stéphan Z dans le monde d'hier qui
regrette l'époque avant la Première
Guerre mondiale o il y avait pas de
passeport on a oublié ça et après la
Première Guerre mondiale il y a eu des
des congrès tenus par la Société des
nations
pour abolir les passeports qui avaient
été conçu commandême une mesure
provisoire pendant la guerre alors là
vous parlez d'un temps sans
frontièrear libertaire qui parle juste
pour dire que quand on parle euh de la
mondialisation du monde ouvert dans
lequel nous vivons et cetera faut
prendre juste un peu de recul historique
et se rendre compte que les
frontières la la rigidité des frontières
actuelles dans le monde est un phénomène
au fond très nouveau et quand même pas
très sympathique pour l'humanité qui je
le rappelle est une espèce et que cette
espèce va devoir résoudre un problème
qui la concerne tout entière h celui de
la planète on termine avec vous Vincent
vouz revenir sur cette incursion des des
chars des tanqus Israéliens sont entrés
à Gaza ce matin alors l'incursion
terrestre qui était donc menée ce jeudi
avant l'eau par l'armée d'Israël dans le
nord de la bande de Gaza ne marque pas
le déclenchement de l'offensive XXL
annoncée elle en constitue en quelque
sorte le prélude opérationnel en croire
l'étatmajor de Tahal il s'agit à l'aide
de blindés et de bulldozer de je cite
préparer le champ de bataille d'ouvrir
dans un tissu urbain dense et piégeux
des axes de pénétration tout en frappant
via des raides supposément ciblés des
postes de tir du Hamas auun mortier ou
roquette antichar elle est inévitable
cette offensive Washington peut bien
inciter son allié à la retenue l'Union
européenne peut plaider en faveur d'une
pause humanitaire le secrétaire général
de l'ONU Antonio gouterch réclamé un
cesser le feu humanitaire et bien
immédiat Emmanuel Macron peut lui aussi
au terme de sa tournée régionale éclair
juger qu'un assaut massif au sol serait
une erreur celui-ci semble inéluctable
la question n'est pas de savoir s'il
surviendra mais à quelle date et sous
quelle forme cuite de son ampleur et de
sa durée mystère l'histoire nous
enseigne l'impossibilité de prédire
quand et dans quel état un acteur
militaire réputé supérieur sort d'une
telle expédition punitive or l'enjeu du
temps est crucial il y aurait pour
Israël autant de risqu à agir trop tôt
que trop tard le sort d'environ 200
otages et les injonctions américaines
interdisent toute précipitation mais
différer le passage à l'acte exposerait
l'État hébreux à épuiser le crédit
compassionnel que lui vaut l'abjecte
barbarie des crimes du 7 octobre et que
ronge déjà le calvaire infligé aux
Palestiniens de Res aériens en barrage
d'artillerie alors qui pour qui
travaille le temps et bien pour personne
personne personne et surtout pas pour
les civils évoqués à l'instant s'il
réaffirme le droit et le devoir d'Israël
de se défendre Joe Biden invite son
partenaire à faire tout son possible
pour épargner les innocents le hic c'est
que tout ça ne suffira pas rien ne
serurait enrayé le naufrage de cette
enclave côtière insalubre et surpeuplé
étranglé depuis 2007 par un blocus quasi
total soumise qui plusé au jou d'un
pouvoir islamiste despotique cynique et
béliqueux chronique d'un désastre
annoncé quelques dizaines de camions ont
franchi en une semaine le post-frontière
de Rafa la belle affaire il en faudrait
à minima une centaine par jour la survie
de dizaines de milliers d'êtres humains
dont le seul tort est d'être né au
mauvais endroit au mauvais moment dépend
de l'acheminement de secours vitaux de
l'eau potable des vivres des médicaments
du carburant pour alimenter les
générateurs des rares hôpitaux encore en
service et les soutiens d'Israël
l'Occident prôent à Israël une riposte
juste oui la formule à la beauté des
oxyorts HE qu'on se rassure il n'y a
d'ailleurs pas dans mon propos la
moindre 11ce de candur oublions un
instant l'impératif moral l'équité et
l'injustice l'inanité du concept de
châtiment collectif concentrons-nous sur
les seuls critères de l'efficacité et de
l'intérêt bien compris celui d'Israël
serait-il vraiment de précipiter
l'éclosion d'une nouvelle génération de
Vengeurs génération perdue qui n'aurait
d'autres horizon que la haine jeunesse
arabe broyée par les rouages infernaux
de la désespérance et de l'éternelle
revanche peut-être y aura-t-il à Gaza
dans un mois dans 6 mois ou au-delà un
vainqueur par défaut mais il n'y aura
pas de gagnant là est l'unique certitude
merci elle est elle est bien sombre
cette chronique mais comme toujours très
très bien écrite merci à vous deux les
affranchis merci Elsa et Merci à VOUS
Gaspard cuning il faut lire humus aux
éditions de l'Observatoire on saura
quand mardi prochain passiam mais
l'autre pour le concours allez on croise
les doigts à demain très belle soirée
[Musique]
documentaire